filling a local job shortage Mary Jane
beliesa takes us to the Las Vegas
Convention Center with how the county
and all other agency partners are making
the most out of their job fair
Andrea butcher is looking for a change
and has already applied for a number of
positions within the city state and
County so my goal was to come and
actually get a contact for somebody that
I could you know ask where am I at in
the process I know there's so many
people that want to work there's so many
people that want jobs you know they
might they run into certain barriers
whether it's financially of not being
able to you know have a computer which
is why Clark County Human Resources
Director Curtis Germany says job fairs
like these are much more important to
bring employment opportunities to the
community it's a great opportunity and
every and every agency is different
right and that's why I really
encouraging people to come out and see
what it's all about around 23 government
agencies were present at Tuesday's job
fair ranging from Public Works health
and more I think coming out of covid
obviously a lot has changed right but I
think for the public sector in general
it's been it's been even heavier not
just here in the valley but Across the
Nation as I talk to my peers because a
lot of times public sector isn't always
the first job right that people think of
assistant fire chief Mack Travis says
job recruitment is always ongoing
because the testing process is in
two-year increments we don't have a
specific number that we're looking to
hire but just for a point of reference
we started the rookie School of 107
people in January and we plan to run
another Public School of 100 people this
August for those like Shawna Williams
getting hired on the spot is a big
relief it feels good to me you know just
to come in because it's actually my
first time coming to a job fair so this
experience just to see all the different
companies that are currently open